- [Instructor] Pascale
Ricketts has invented a game
called Three Rolls to 10.
You roll a fair six-sided die three times.
If the sum of the rolls
is 10 or greater, you win.
If it is less than 10, you lose.
What is the probability of
winning Three Rolls to 10?
So, there is several ways
that you can approach this.
The way we're going to
tackle it in this video
is we're going to try to come up
with an experimental probability.
We're going to do many experiments
trying to win Three Rolls to 10
and figure out the proportion
that we actually win
and the more experiments we try,
the better, the more
likely that we're gonna get
a good approximation of
the actual probability.
So, let's do that
and to help us I'm
going to have a computer
generate a string of random digits
from zero to nine.
And the way that we're going
to use this is remember,
we're rolling a fair six-sided die,
so the outcome could be
one, two, three, four,
five or six for each roll.
In this random number list
that the computer has generated,
I do get digits from one to six
but I also get the digits
seven, eight, nine and zero
and so what I'm going to
do for each experiment,
I'm going to start at the top left
and I'm gonna consider each digit a roll.
If it gives me an invalid
result for a six-sided die,
so if it's a zero, an
eight, a seven or a nine
I will just ignore that,
I will just say well,
that wasn't a valid roll.
It's like, you roll the die
and it fell off the table
or something like that.
So, let's do that.
Let's do multiple experiments
of taking three rolls, sum them up
and we'll see how many we can do
to figure out an experimental probability
of winning Pascale's game.
So, let me set up a little table here,
so I want space to show the sum,
so this is going to be the experiment,
experiment, actually let me write the sum
and over here we're gonna say did we win?
Alright.
So, let's start with experiment one.
So, our first roll we got a one.
Our second roll we got a five.
We're doing quite well
and then our third roll we got a six.
Did we win?
Well, one plus five plus six is 12.
Yes, we won.
Let's do another experiment.
This is going to be experiment two.
We can just keep going here.
These are random digits.
So, we have a six in our first roll.
We got a two in our second roll,
we got a four in our third roll.
Did we win?
Yes, once again this summed up to 12.
So, we won.
Alright, let's do another experiment.
So, experiment number three.
So, this first thing is invalid,
so this is our first roll.
We got a six,
and then this is invalid.
Our second roll we get a three,
this is invalid, that is invalid,
that is invalid and then in our third roll
we got a two, so we squeaked by.
This adds up to 11.
Yes, that looks like a win.
Alright, let's do our
fourth experiment here.
So, our first roll we got a one.
This is invalid.
Second roll we got a two.
Third roll we get a five.
Did we win?
One plus two plus five is eight.
No, we did not win.
So, that was our first non-win.
So, let's keep going.
This is interesting.
Alright, this is invalid,
so we're going to have,
so this is trial five,
we're going to have four
plus three plus one.
Four plus three plus one,
adds up to eight.
Did we win?
No.
Let's just keep going here.
So, I'm gonna keep going with my table
where I have experiment,
I'll do five more trials, experiment,
sum and do we win?
Let me make the table.
This is just a continuation
of the table we had before.
I don't want to go below the page
'cause I wanna be able to look
at our random numbers here.
So, we are onto experiment six.
Experiment six, we are getting
a three in the first roll,
a three in the second roll,
this isn't looking good
and then a two in our third roll.
Did we win?
No, this is less than 10.
Now we go to experiment seven.
Experiment seven.
We get a two in our first roll.
This is invalid.
We get a three in our
second roll, plus three
and we get a one in our
third roll, so plus one.
Once again we did not win.
Now we go to experiment,
we will go to experiment eight.
We get a one in our first roll,
we get a three in our second row,
this is invalid, the
die fell off the table,
we could think of it that way
and then in our third roll
we get a five, plus five.
Did we win?
No, this adds up to nine.
So, we had a string of wins to begin with
but now we're getting
a strong of non-wins.
Alright.
Now, let's go to experiment nine.
So, we get a six in our first roll,
we get a four in our second roll
and then these are all invalid,
and then we got a five in our third roll.
Did we win here?
Yes, we won over here.
This is definitely going
to be greater than 10,
this is 15 here.
Alright, last experiment
or at least for this
video, last experiment.
You could keep going.
In fact, I encourage you to after this
and see if you can get a more accurate,
a better approximation of
the theoretical probability
of winning by doing more experiments
to calculate an experimental probability.
So, here experiment 10.
First roll we get a five,
second roll we get a two,
this is invalid, invalid, invalid,
then we get a six.
Here we definitely won.
So, with 10 trials, based on 10 trials
or 10 experiments,
what is our experimental
probability of winning this game?
Well, out of the 10 experiments
how many did we win?
Well, it looks like we won
one, two, three, four, five.
So, based on just these 10 experiments
we got a pretty clean 50%.
So, do you think the
theoretical probability
is actually 50%?
Maybe you'd want to continue
running these experiments
over and over.
Maybe we'd want to do a computer program
that could run this experiment
instead of 10 times,
maybe 10,000 times
to see if we can get closer
to the true theoretical probability.